dein neues Buch eine Neuerscheinung
heißt passend auch Neuerscheinung
ähm wie kommt es zu so ein Titel jetzt
habe ich die ganze Zeit gedacht wie ist
die Lage wen erste Frage eine wunderbare
Antwort über nein Gottes will nein nein
wir fangen jetzt genauso wie wie kommt
man auf den
Titel auf den Titel bin ich gar nicht
selber gekommen auf den Titel ist mein
Verlag gekommen ich hatätte eigentlich
ursprünglich gedacht dass Buch muss die
Messias heißen weil es mehr polarisiert
die waren der Meinung vielleicht
polarisiert ist zu viel es einfach
Neuerscheinung und passt ja und ist
seonal unabhängig und passt im nächsten
Jahr immer noch V daher ein guter Titel
gut es ist immer eine Neuerscheinung das
ist natürlich klasse also trotzdem dann
meine Eingangsfrage wie ist die Lage
endlich brach mich das ja optimistisch
aber mit wachem Blick auf die
unwkbarkeiten des Lebens klingt total
spontan oder das klingt total spontan
ähm optimistisch unwegbarkeit ich
versuche das gerade intellektuell zu
verarbeiten merkst das es dauert ein
Biss bisschen länger das war die Absicht
welche unwerkbarkeiten auf welche
stellst du dich da ein ach es gibt ja so
viele ich finde ich habe einfach Grund
optimistisch zu sein zu Zeit warum weil
es mir gut geht weil ich ein paar gute
Sachen gemacht habe und ein paar gute
Sachen machen werde aber ich habe eben
diesen Blick noch auf alles was draußen
passiert und da gibt's ein paar Dinge
die vi ich nicht ganz so Prickeln und
die habe ich schon Blick und da achte
ich sehr drauf von daher optimistisch
ich selber aber mit Blick auf die
Unwegbarkeiten die mich natürlich auch
überholen können ja wobei unwegbarkeit
ist ja wahrscheinlich auch selber ein
Buch schreiben weil viele Kollegen
erzählen ja Geld kann man damit nicht
unbedingt verdienen es kommt drauf an
wenn man natürlich ein Bestseller wird
aber sag so die Lage im Moment die Lage
ist auch nicht so verzweifelt wie sie im
Buchbereich generell sein könnte und ist
es läuft ganz gut es läuft überraschend
gut es läuft nicht ganz so gut wie bei
Büchern die sich sag mit mit mit
analfisuren und ähnlichen Themen
beschäftigen die noch stärker auf den
Gong hauen es geht ja nur um die Messias
und nicht um den Analbereich aber
ich glaub den todsicheren Erfolg wollte
ich überhaupt nicht sonst hätte ich
wahrscheinlich auch lieber über solche
Dinge geschrieben und in dem Buch gibt
es einen Autor der dieses Buch wiederum
schreibt aber in der Rolle einer Frau er
ist eine Frau die dieses Buch schreibt
richtig ähm das liegt einfach daran dass
ich eigentlich nur die Geschichte
schreiben wollte von die Messias aber
hinter allen erfolgsstoffen steckt ja
eine Frau in dem Fall sogar meine eigene
die hat gemeint das reicht nicht für den
ganzen Roman und es ist einfach nur nur
provokativ und sie sagte sucht in der
Geschichte um diese Geschichte herum und
da kam ich eben auf diesen Helden Paul
elmlitten der diesen Roman schreiben
möchte um seine Zeitung zu retten er
schreibt ja einen Fortsetzungsroman und
er hat natürlich diese diese Eigenschaft
eines subgutanen Helden also er ist ganz
ganz großartig aber nach außen eben
nicht und weil er Angst hat vor seiner
eigenen Frau die bei der katholischen
Kirche arbeitet schreibt er unter
Pseudonym als Bella Gabor diesen Roman
mm
Desi Romane zum Preis von ein
sensationell und äh du hast ja folgende
Geschichte ist ja du hast moderiert im
WDR sehr erfolgreich aber da hat man
dann kein neues Format für dich gefunden
öffentlichrechtlicher Sender halt dann
hast du unglaublich viel Comedy
geschrieben sehr erfolgreich grimmepreis
alles Atze
U900 Kinofilm warhaup nicht erfolgreich
erfolgreich war ncola und Ritas wel das
war war
ja ab der so erscheint dass man gerade
noch den Namen lesen kann wenn man genug
Zeit hätte hat man aber nicht also der
Autor geht eigentlich unter die im
Dunkeln das Prinzip ja ja genau dunkel
sieht man nicht nee aber das heißt Eidel
klar ich finde es schöner mit einem Buch
mehr in Verbindung gebracht zu werden in
der Außenwahrnehmung also ein Buch zu
schreiben und zu wissen aha das ist der
Auto beim Fernsehen ist eben nicht so
erschwerend hinzu kommt dass im
Fernsehen alles was man macht verklappt
ist es ist einfach weg und so ein Buch
nehme ich in die Hand und dann sage ich
mir guck mal das hast Du und da muss ich
nicht drauf warten dass irgendwann
wiederholt wird und da bin ich auch mit
recht stolzer drauf glaube ich als auf
jede Form von Fernsehpräsenz also von
von der inaktiven Fernsehpräsenz und ein
Buch hat für mich auch den Vorteil dass
ich mich
komplett damit verschreiben kann im
warahsten Sinn des Wortes auch verbinden
kann bei Serien und Fernsehen und Film
ist immer so dass natürlich ganz ganz
viele Menschen damit zu tun haben wenn
es darum geht den Erfolg zu strecken
dann ist es natürlich im Erfolgsfall der
begnadete carst der super schaspieler
die wunderbare Regie die hervorragende
Maskenbildnerin und irgendwann
vielleicht auch noch das Buch ich würde
lügen wenn ich behaupten würde dass mir
total egal ist ich finde es schon
manchmal auch fahrlässig also die
Grundlage eines Filmes so irgendwo
abzuhaken dass man das Gefühl hat man
kommt knapp vor der vor der vor der
kompasserie okay und und mein Buch eben
nicht und es reden einem 100 Leute noch
rein die es nicht schuld sind wenn es
ein Misserfolg wird und die es schuld
sind und verantwortlich sind wenn es ein
Erfolg wird das wäre die einfache Formel
im Flop war natürlich immer schlechte
Buch das ist ja klar also mit so ein
Buch kann man kein Erfolg machen beim
Erfolg eines Films oder einer Serie gibt
es Millionen von Parametern die an
diesem Erfolg maßgeblich beteiligt waren
aber beim Buch ist es auch du kannst da
deinen eigenen Schuh machen es redet ja
keiner rein oder wie ist das mit dem
Lektor beim Verlag zusammen zuuarbeiten
sagen wir mal so wenn man die Idee
einmal verkauft hat und sagt ich möchte
gerne ein Buch schreiben über einen
Lokalredakteur der eine Geschichte
schreibt über die Schwester von Jesus
dann ist man ab dem Moment wo das Buch
wirklich verkauft ist wir autag in
seiner Entscheidung auch in seiner
Ausführung beim Fernsehen ist es nicht
so da schreibe ich sagen mal ein Expose
wo es um singende Matrosen geht und ich
schreibe 24 Folgen von über singende
Matrosen alle sagen hinreißendes Thema
aber wir hätten gerne irgendwas über
schießende Jäger das heißt klar wenn ich
dann Geld brauche sage ich kein Thema
ich schreib alle 24 Folgen komplett
wieder um aber es sind nicht mehr meine
Folgen es ist nicht mehr mein Matrose
der singt S ist der schießende Jäger das
heißt man macht irgendwo um es ganz böse
auszudrücken eine schreiberische
Prostitution man tut das was der Kunde
will und nicht was man selber möchte
beim Buch ist e anders und das ist der
entscheidende Vorteil wie siehst du da
deine Zukunft möchtest du verstärkt in
diese Richtung gehen oder braucht man
zum Leben das Schreiben fürs f
ansehen wenn es so etwas geäbe wie
zuguft nach Zahlen wo ich also quasi nur
ausmalen muss dann würde ich sagen dann
schreibe ich einmal im Jahr ein Roman
den ich total klasse finde und mach noch
einen oder zwei Filme die ich auch
klasse finde und zwar so wie ich es
gerne möchte inhaltlich bisschenin zur
Ausführung das wäre mein Idealzustand da
wir aber in Deutschland nicht das
Prinzip Wunschkonzert kennen werde ich
wohl ein Roman pro Jahr schreiben und
noch ein paar
Dinge die ich mir dann zu Silvester
regelmäßig schön Rede gut ähm trauerst
du denn der Zeit als du moderiert hast
beim WDR nach ist das so ein karrierearm
wo du gesagt hättest das hätte ich
lieber weiter gemacht
ähm die Zeit glaube ich der der ganz
ganz aktiven Trauer ist zu Ende schon so
paar jah sie gab's ja ja klar ich habe
natürlich auch gedacht warum erkennen
die mich nicht warum sehen die dieses
wahnsinnspotenzial nicht warum
verschenken die Talente die
kurze anreisen haben nach Köln und
hab dann immer gesagt ist halt so ich
bin eben nicht der Moderator den sie
wollen und mittlerweile bin ich damit
auch einigermaßen okay also zufrieden
und weiß dass ich meine Nische gefunden
habe die ich ausführen kann eben das
Schreiben das Autoren da sein aber es
gab schon eine verletzte eelkeit klar
und was hat da geholfen das zu
verarbeiten Erfolge beim Schreiben ich
glaub wenn das auch noch gefloppt hätte
dann hätte ich mich wahrscheinlich
irgendwann fliehen müssen in
Berufsfelder die mir zu tiefst zu wieder
sind und da habe ich noch richtig Glück
gehabt habt und welche Berufsfelder
wären das gewesen ja z.B Soziologie also
so diese Geschichten lange lange
Expertisen schreiben oder
wissenschaftliche Betrachtung über das
Wanderverhalten von Portugiesen im
Mittelalter bis hin zu
migrationsschwierigkeiten und solchen
Dingen hochspannende Themen aber nicht
für mich mm also beim neuen live WST du
nicht gelandet das also da hätte ich
glaube ich lieber Landschaftsgärtnerei
betrieben und zwar mit nacktten
Oberkörper auch im Winter bevor ich zu
neuen
geh weil ich sag mal die ganze wenn man
Fernsehen heute sieht und was für
Moderatoren Typen gewünscht werden dann
sind das ja eher die gradlenig
gebürsteten lieber Kollege von dir
Robert treutel der hat ja inzwischen
auch von sich aus aufgegeben weil er das
gar nicht mehr ertragen konnte dass man
gecoacht wird bis zur
stromlingförmigkeit und einfach nur noch
wie wie ein rederoboter da sitzt leider
W aber Rober hat seine n gefunden der
macht ein einen wunderbaren bodo Bach
der ist Kabarettist geworden und dem
ernsthaften Journalismus wahrscheinlich
entzogen aber zu seinem Wohle und
wahrscheinlich auch zum woh der
Zuschauer ich finde das toll was er da
macht ist das so ein Zeichen der RE für
die Reise wohin die Medien im Moment
gehen dass Leute wie du einfach nicht
eingesetzt werden Leute wie Robert
trutel sagen das kann ich nicht machen
ach sag mal so es gibt ja schon noch
eine ganze Zahl Anzahl von von
Moderatoren ich auch toll finde die auch
ihren Job richtig gut
machen wenn ich davon aus dass es
natürlich sehr viele stromlinienförmige
gibt wie das zurecht sagst auch die auch
eine einheitliche Gewichtsklasse
komischerweise haben also die gehen
glaube ich maximal bis 85 kg haben
solche Kreuzchen und so ein Popo und das
war's dann auch und damit erfüllen ich
schon mal nach außen hin das Prinzip
Moderator wenn ich das so sehe würde ich
sagen in dieses Raster pass ich eh nicht
rein da passt auch Robert treutel nicht
rein weil wir beide wahrscheinlich auch
nicht hübsch genug sind aber wenn hübsch
plötzlich auch ein Indikator ist für
gutes moderieren würde ich sagen ja dann
bin ich auch froh dass ich in dem
Bereich nicht mehr unterwegs bin das
meine ich wirklich ohne jede Häme mhm es
gibt ein paar unhübsche Moderatoren die
auch sehr gut sind ich glaube es gibt
eine hohe Korrelation zwischen wenig
attraktiv und gut moderieren umgekehrt
aber auch mhm weil man gut moderieren
muss um abzulenken von von seiner
unattrtiv hast du jetzt gesagt ja ich
finde Jörg tadeus ist auch nicht gerade
ein hübscher Kerl also ganz objektiv das
kann ich auch als Mann glaube ich sagen
aber er ist ein hinreißender Moderator
und ich gucke mir den gerne an und ich
gucke ih ganz bestimmt nicht gerne an
weil er für mich aussieht wie die
deutsche ANB auf Brad Pitt aber er sieht
aus wie jemand den man gerne zuhören
möchte von daher das war gleich mal mit
neuen live D weißt du ganz genau was ich
meine gut vielen Dank bitte